welcome back everybody to frenemies
number three they said we wouldn't even
make it past the first episode and here
we are three episodes deep
no end in sight yet not yet but i did i
was saying this past weekend that it
might be
because what you guys were already kind
of annoying me this weekend and i'm like
honestly what
either break up with you guys or snap on
you guys one of the two will come
eventually but so far so good oh well
hold on first of all we have a sponsor
thank you to adam and eve
um why what did i do this weekend i
didn't even talk
to you literally
you at midnight texting get a cover test
before monday and then
right when i wake up ela being like oh
go to this place
it's only 15 minutes and then i'm like
okay but then moses like with his nose
test he's like oh we had to do the
throat it was just overwhelming oh
that's only 15 minutes and you can go
here and i was just like this is so
overwhelming just be like
hey get a cover test but then last night
at midnight you text me and you're like
what should we talk about tomorrow i'm
like it's midnight like i'm in bed like
you're just a lot like you always text a
lot you're so
if i could let me get my phone and the
what's that
you literally are saying i'm gonna break
i'm gonna end the show
let me read the text that i actually
sent you just
just to compare your version of reality
to what actually happened
let's see i said hmm
let's first of all i just i want to get
this on the record
i'm text i'm finding it too yeah okay
it's
it's all of it we're in a separate
whatsapp you and me no in front of me is
what
no no no this is the only one i talked
to about and i said
i said at 10 04 p.m 104 on a friday
night
you mean sunday oh well well i'm working
to prepare the show so that it's
actually
entertaining 10 19 why are you texting
me and then here and then
let me tell you what happened before let
me explain the reality
i said all i said was trisha anything
you want to talk about tomorrow
anything on your mind at 10 04 p.m you
said i'm never sure until we start
laughing crying emoji i said no worries
i got some stuff planned i just figured
i'd ask see you tomorrow
that was the entirety of the
conversation friday
do you mind testing after that music
video before monday and i was like
before i could even hold on hold on
you're giving it this franticness that's
not there
you guys were friendly because i'm like
yep we tested everyone i sent the
screenshots of all the chests we got
from dancers
anyways i'm like there's a place we'll
go to ten to one i'll go today
blah blah blah they don't film anything
and then ela 901 so before like we're
even like awake and everything
if you try urgent med they give results
in 15 minutes there's one in beverly
hills last time we started up with the
only ones there the test is called the
antigen and then i'm like is another
throat and knows i said okay well we
can't go there because we can't do the
nose
then and then it's like whatever you
prefer and then you're like thank you
and then it's like then i had to send
the text why are you
you why are you like having a panic
attack this isn't our fault
okay but then like in the solo one and
then the day that the podcast post
i mean i love it and i thank you for
sending me all the things but we're
going back and forth so much
like you know what i mean the day of
like it's just so you're saying you
don't like talking to me
oh and then oh this is what oh this is
what the annoying thing is on the front
of me
and solo you were trying to ask me who
the disney soda fountain story was about
and you asked me twice i was just
[ __ ] around oh and i but i ignored
you both times and then in the separate
one
you're like okay we'll do this whatever
we're talking about something totally
different and then you're like okay but
tell me who was the person second time
asking me i was just [ __ ] around
i was just chatting with a friend i mean
we're not friends
we're not friends like that okay sorry
no you weren't studying with a friend
by the way
oh my god and then with moses family
just everyone coming at me and now your
family apparently
everyone's families hate me and i'm like
you know what this isn't working there's
too many there's just too many
okay let's break let's slow down let's
catch a breath
and deconstruct first of all can you
show a profile shot because everybody
was
noticing that you're like i guess you
have extensions so it looks like there's
a wig underneath feel it oh it is
feel it go like that oh [ __ ] so so it
just adds
volume back here yeah it's like a brat
style they might look as breath it's not
halloween we're preparing for halloween
that's the other annoying thing can i
just say
try okay i announced last week okay
we're new fun halloween costumes
literally right away okay we need a
coordinate and then i'm like throwing
out ideas and then you're like not those
ideas they say i'm like you know what
let me just go with my costumes that i
wanted
because i didn't think you were gonna
dress up anyways i'm down for the last
idea
but i was trying to throw ideas like not
that not that it's through this this is
this i'm like never mind it's not that
big of a deal i'm just gonna come
dressed
you want me to read those conversations
no because i take up the whole life
no it was like three lines you're like
do you want to go as howard stern
and anna nicole smith no i gave you many
options i said favorite jew
and you did not like that one i was like
trisha let's not go as our favorite jew
i'm not trying to lean into that i have
so many i either want to be eugene love
you or adam sandler unlike you i'm not
trying to lean into this weird jew
fetishism okay we're over the jew talk
but then
favorite horror movie character i
thought was a good one me too
you said no to all three except the one
ela said which is a good idea had a
great idea i like love that idea and i'm
excited to do that totally i'll i'll
sacrifice one of my costumes
but i've been preparing for this since
august i'm in i'm down
my cost that's why i was like trying to
figure out overall genres that i can
still wear the costumes i had prepared
all right let me read the conversation
no no no no
because because it's not like it's not
it's like
it's not what you get no you're gonna
start from me being a mean manic person
you guys were like
yeah because you were like okay we're
about to film and mind you this was the
day before my music video so before my
music video i am doing
the [ __ ] most i'm just thinking hold
on hold on hold on hold on
just slow down you seem really caustic
today
what's caustic you just seem like super
like explosive
you got me really excited about
disneyland honestly earlier but that's a
totally different story
and i had a dream about you last night
but it was about gay sex because you've
been doing so many duets with like hot
guys on tick tock
we're gonna talk about this but i didn't
and i was just thinking about this last
night i just had such a vivid dream of
you like getting banged by two guys and
i was like oh my god this is so awkward
because i was coming today like it's so
weird i never dreamed about you i don't
even think about you like outside
you are way crazy today you are like
crazier than normal today i had a
slushie and a coffee and dunkin donuts
this morning
chocolate holes the munchkins which
moses spit back out
so anyway i want to talk about your hair
though because it gives you these
really long extensions but it looks like
your head is shaped like a fishbowl or
something
you like how you makes your head look
prolonged because it makes me look
skinnier
it makes it look like you had like a
birth defect or something
okay it makes me look tiny like how tiny
i like this i'm so skinny
last time i looked huge i looked like i
was so close to the camera i looked like
your size i was like oh my god i'm not
that big but also
you're kind of skinny 226. why i'm down
i'm blue i'm working on it what you
that's like that's literally what i
weigh that was like what the [ __ ]
yeah but i'm like four inches taller
than you or something
but you look bigger than me but you're
not
how is that possible i'm four inches
taller but that means
but you weigh the same yeah that's well
you know what i'm saying like
that's not good for you but you weigh
220.
well no i think i'm like 200 but yeah my
200 for sure
[ __ ] first of all thank you for saying
that boobs i weighed my boobs one time
on a grocery scale and they were 30
pounds so i really
did that i swear all the time oh my god
yeah that's why you gotta like take the
bike in and stuff that was a whole
different conversation but
um so when you're going to get your
what happened when you go to get your
boobs done
is do they have more lightweight
material maybe yeah i'm gonna try and
get them done again i think you could
get like the gummy bears are lighter
right now mine's still a cone
so let's talk about the family drama
first of all let's start light let's
talk with my family
about my family i didn't know this until
this morning that my family had a
problem with me
no no they don't they was they were
bitching at me because they're like we
worked super hard
on the dinner and you guys were saying
it was [ __ ] were they offended for real
well i know i didn't think so but but
like i was like dude we always
joke about how our dinners suck and like
our yom kippurs are like half assed
wait you're the poorest fasting though
or rosh hashanah sorry
happy yom kippur yesterday don't you
mean
yum kipper i'm just kidding stupid
that's how you used to say it in israel
to piss everyone out moses told me i
couldn't do any trolling tech talks on
that day he's like this is a very
serious holiday so you should not be
posting
oh good job moses because it's getting
out of control and
someone needed to [ __ ] reign this
[ __ ] in dude
yeah you if someone had to reign the
[ __ ] in anyway so anyway
but yeah i was kind of surprised by that
because i was like i was i was just like
we
we always shoot on each other's meal
that was it they just i say
your guys families both of yours are the
only people that ever get like offended
by stuff i say like that
i was very surprised and it was it was
only one member it wasn't the other
so anyway i know who never gonna say it
but you want to guess
definitely your mom no it wasn't she
didn't say hi to me when i walked in so
my mom my mom likes you another family
my mom likes
it was a lot and i still feel a little
ptsd for my homework ptsd
from what from just being there yeah
damn you're sensitive
imagine if you actually went to war or
something
nope anyways um it's fine okay let's
talk about uh
hands your our collab bro
only i wouldn't do that for a billion
[ __ ] dollars like a showering video
you wouldn't just shower with me like
take a shower nothing sexual
not even for t not even for 10 million
would you imagine if we just stood next
to each other naked in the shower just
like doing a shower like
why do you why do you think anyone would
pay for that they would
why split it we could split the money
you love money
we talk about this you are driven by
money i don't love money that much
you wouldn't do it not even comedy
aren't you i swear to god
i wouldn't do it i wouldn't do it for
any amount of money but like elon moses
could be there
if jeff bezos was like i'm gonna give
you guys a billion dollars
if you take a shower together i'd be
like [ __ ] you jeff bezos you sick
[ __ ] don't you have a better use of your
money you're starving kids and you're
offering me a billion dollars do it oh
my god you would do it now i feel like
you want to because i know like you've
always had an inch towards wanting to do
an only fans
and this is like your segway in
no well i'm saying no i'm flat out i
can't wait for our shoot this week so so
here's what happened
with um with with ela's family
and moses and family so so moses posted
a picture
on instagram to his stories correct me
if i'm wrong
of of him and you in lingerie
and i guess well he
moses hasn't moses
i don't know if they know what you do
for a living or yeah they have fun yes
and so and and i don't think that moses
and frankly moses has done a terrible
job of explaining his relationship as he
always does
i mean he did it to with to me and ela
he didn't explain anything and we're
close with him and i don't know what he
has to hide from us because we're not
judgmental i don't think you guys are
close as you think but
continue like i don't think there's a
closeness okay go ahead and try to drive
a wedge between me and my brother-in-law
you freak
you know you're not close i mean we're
have a level of familiarity
we're working on like the house and
stuff but not like hey like how's it
going okay
whatever i'm not even going to argue the
closeness of my relationship with you
not obviously not with you i mean he he
hasn't put his dick in my butt if that's
what you mean
so sure there's a different familiarity
of course
okay anyway okay
so anyway they saw this picture of moses
and you and lingerie
and they got super freaked out and you
know in israel it's like a different
it's like different it's you know what i
mean is it though
it is we just watched zohan last night
and the girls were all in half naked
bikinis like it's even you know
you know bro
they were at the beginning in the
television section i'm speechless
zohan he says it's accurate i watch it
with an israeli
zohan's accurate what about zohan is
accurate
don't you say it is you say it is
anyways he says it is
he's not stop stop let me focus
so anyway they saw the picture of them
in the lingerie
and they got i think one they're
offended his family as a whole
is offended that he's not telling them
more i get that yeah
and the same remember when me and ela
had a problem it was the same thing just
we're like what is happening
he doesn't say anything and now all of a
sudden they're taking photos
so that so i don't think they're even
mad at i'll be honest i talk to them
they have no problem with you they like
lingerie scandal yeah
oh they like you
i'll give you the whole story hold on
hold on no no no not getting
to understand why he doesn't like he's
talking let me talk i get why he's
distancing himself from everybody
stop before fyi stop let me talk
it's they're mad at moses they like you
they have no problem with you they're
like
why isn't moses telling us it's the same
problem meaning ila had
and so they have this genuine shock when
they're like
their fear is that moses will do a porno
with you
and getting closer to that and if he
does that i'm just saying
it's been said that because
because all of his extended family and
they're all super conservative oh gee
you know what i'm saying
right for sure my family is two thousand
no no it's different
it's not you don't know anything about
israel even though you
make a bunch of jew videos and all this
[ __ ] and
just because you eat falafel doesn't
mean you know anything about israel
i say hebrew no you don't a little bit
okay whatever so anyway they are afraid
if he does a porno
to hot like like what
the heck what
no please anyways i said it good did i
thank you babe okay so so are you
listening to me yes okay but i'm saying
my family is also very conservative
but they don't have room to be like oh
like they're mad at him
okay but then hit like all the extended
families now like they saw the photo and
they're calling
his family being like what's going on
what is this the photo by the way isn't
it i agree
and so when i heard i'll tell you what
happened so when i heard
ila recapped the convo to me and then
when i heard
how they were reacting i was like oh
that seems like way
they're they're i said one i don't think
moses is going to do porno he already
said he's not and i don't think he would
we do have a hidden folder on the phone
and two um
i said two i think they're overreacting
i think that i don't think the photo's
that bad
and so i got on the phone with them to
try to calm them down oh they were
hysterical or what why are you
no they weren't hysterical but i just
wanted to i was i was speaking in your
defense frankly
yeah thank you i appreciate that and i
think i think it all stems from moses
not being open with his
who cares if he does a porno he's 42
years old he's like what the hell
well well you know i i have the same
opinion as you but it's different there
which you don't understand okay but why
this is why we're not all equal okay
why don't you just go to syria okay
if you go to saudi arabia and they're in
israel and they just continue to be
little and
sheltered and stuff like that what do
you mean they're little it's only seven
million people like
la's bigger than that like what's up you
know you don't know anything about but
it's a small piece of land i
know where it is i showed it to me on
the map the first time you saw it on a
map
why he ran away at 17. there's a reason
people leave israel they don't stay
there
no offense israel do you want to come
with you but damn did a flip-flop on
israel real fast
mostly just moses's family that are
judging me right now the ones that are
the ones that are again they're
they're not they're accepting of you
it's just i want him to do a porno with
me that's what i do
why can't he do that why is that wrong
why is that bad we all have sex my
parents know i do porno so like what
like
i feel like i feel like you are not
working hard enough
to empathize with his situation
it's you you do you understand like i do
no you're not
you're saying hey america is this way so
the whole world should be this way
but he knew and i said from the
beginning i'm like guess what families
aren't comfortable with this like
my last relationship you can date and
not make a porno with your spouse
okay so okay fine most is accepting of
that but you don't have to [ __ ] him on
camera what if he wants to do that what
if that's his choice
well then i'm sure he can but he has to
take in consideration
other factors because there's more
to the world than the united states do
you understand that certainly his family
why do you have to like live your life
to like oh but my family might think
about this like live your life like
jesus like
live your life like i just don't get
that like yeah my dad's so conservative
my dad's like uh
okay you know you know mia khalifa she's
lebanese she follows me on tick-tock
she's she lebanese is a conservative
country even though there's more
conservative countries
to be frank and when she did porn she
got like death threats people wanted to
kill her
okay okay i'm just telling you cultures
are different israel's not lebanon i'm
scared about that
no people aren't going to try to kill
him but i'm just i'm trying to explain
what you're not
getting but we're in a very specific
it's me and him it's not
we're not talking about lebanon right
now you know you're not not in my [ __ ]
you know
it's one person like jesus it's not the
country lebanon isn't in your [ __ ]
not at the moment we can fit it in there
i get a feeling
um um anyway but i feel like you are not
you are you are being very selfish i ask
him all the time i'm like
like and i feel and i'm just telling you
that you're gonna push him
to the point either you're because
you're so persistent you're so
persistent and you're so uncaring about
his situation
so not true that you're gonna force him
into the situation and you're gonna ruin
his [ __ ] life
and by the way moses has a lot of
profession like he's not a porn star
like you okay he he's a professional
he's not doing porn with me
right now he doesn't want to shower with
me i asked him so it's not even close
but i
feel like you will just hammer on him
until he breaks
i'm fine with it i'm fine with it i'm
honestly fine with it okay so i know
when then we'll move on from moses and
his family specifically
ila texted him about something and said
is this true she you guys screenshot
comments what what'd she say you can say
what
comments from these podcasts you guys
screenshot sent to moses
is this true are you guys 12 why are you
listening to anonymous commenters being
like oh she's making moses get rid of
his cats and you're like oh my god is
this true i was like
what the [ __ ] moses is 42. he doesn't
even like cats
because he's like they ruin his [ __ ]
like the fact that you guys are moses
doesn't want his cats
moses in my living space so he'll keep
him at the museum and not the house
when i sleep and eat i don't have anyone
thank you
dude it's a non-issue he's like he's
grown you guys act like he's like a 12
year old that doesn't know how to make a
decision no because we're worried about
you you you said it wasn't about me you
said it's about him no someone said so
we saw a comment that said trisha is
making moses get rid of his cat
do you think you have that power what do
you think i can control him like that i
don't know
i don't know in case he'd be doing only
fans like what the [ __ ] like i don't
control him like jesus like but like do
you hear
like dude i don't know let's switch
topics because like this is so it's just
so annoying like i'm so over israelis
and jewish i'm over it that was fast
so no more uh jewish food reviews
no i'm over it i have a bunch of
comments from on the jewish food reviews
i wanted to read you
no more we're like you know more about
jewish people and you checked out my
halloween idea of dressing as other
friends
then god you said are you serious
because it's a little [ __ ] like
weird don't you think we're celebrating
okay how about i was like
let's come dressed as our favorite black
person
i mean that's [ __ ] up it's weird
different because it's a culture i can't
enable this
weird behavior i kind of get what you're
saying okay okay thank you wow thank you
thank you for shooting eugene love you
and adam sandler i was gonna come
dressed half and half as you because
they're my favorite jewish people
i love them and eugene levy's a double
geo how amazing is that even though
those existed
the ones like ashikash and like the
other ones like the middle eastern
you know yeah ashkenazi and safari i
don't think that's a double jew
that is he has parents from he's a
european theodore well theodore's a
double jew then
oh lucky him you're right he's the
chosen one he is chosen he's so much
cuter than
any baby i've seen he's cute
all right we have to take a break and do
our ad read and hope i think this
at least let's get paid once before we
break up i need to recoup the money on
this set
okay sounds good all right let's do it
free
stuff this is stupid i already don't
like it free stuff is awesome
let me do it we were going to do it in
unison well i was reading ahead to see
what it said but
it just feels like too cutesy to do it
together that's awesome
but free stuff to spice up your bedroom
is even
better select almost any one item for
fifty percent off
that's five zero half fifty percent off
and then adam and eve loads on the free
stuff tell them what else is free
thank you for throwing it to me trisha
enter offer code
h3 at checkout and get 10 tantalizing
free
gifts 10 free gifts plus 50 off that's
insane because these toys are expensive
and luxurious but you're getting a
discount
what code is it h3 a sexy item for him
a special gift for her and a third item
i didn't know we're having a threesome
a third item you'll both enjoy plus six
free what could that spicy movie third
item you'll both enjoy oh they have a
couple's one where it kind of like
stimulates him and like a [ __ ] ring that
vibrates it stimulates both of you at
the same time
we know that one hey i mean not you and
me together but
stop don't you can't go there that's
like one of the ground rules of the show
we should do an only fan so we can
promote adam and eve on there i already
by using their toy
and then at the end say get h3 50 off
six free spicy movies ooh that's pretty
[ __ ] i wonder do you get to decide like
how do you know that the movies
are you're sending are your genre
because i feel like
i think there's a universe that wants to
there it's just it's just the universal
game
they wouldn't send like dude [ __ ] on
a girl's chest
i don't think you'd do [ __ ] porn i think
that's like a thing like you can't find
it on pornhub or anything dude once i
was in
um i was in germany when i was 18. and
we went into a porn shop
in the red light district and people
always say like scheisse films like a
[ __ ] film is
it's like a german thing oh yeah and
there were tons of [ __ ]
but here's the thing that really
interested me they were marked up
the [ __ ] porns were more expensive
they're like a new box yeah because you
can't find them in america like you
literally can't find them online
so i wonder if the girls get more for
par for if everyone gets more for
participating
they probably screw the girls too in
every country sad
yeah sad uh plus free shipping
that's h3h3 offer code
h3 at checkout at adamandeve.com and
remember guys if you want more episodes
of frenemies
go to annabenville.com and use code h3
yeah get the sex toys so we can keep
coming back that's the only way i'm
going to continue to do this
if you use the h and remember i'm the
one that's money
focused i didn't say i wasn't okay but
shout out adamn
adame.com h3 50 all right wrap it up
wrap it up
wrap it up plus the gifts for him her
and the both to share
h3 at adamnew.com
okay and we're back welcome back to
frenemies oh you
that was nice you jumped in you took the
lead a little bit i'm getting more
comfortable like it's my show
yeah it is your show you got the whole
thing i always thought we could do like
daytime talk show but then i'm like
we're both kind of like
not that aesthetically pleasing to the
eye like fully i know you have to be
like that's true well we could have a
show called two fatties
and the guests would feel so much more
comfortable because they would like yeah
i think i feel like you
you could you could make a show like
that two big fat idiots two big fat
slobs
could you imagine sitting on those
stools like ryan and kelly a fairy a
fair
affair i'm so dyslexic a hairy fat idiot
and a goal
and a gold fish shaped bimbo
golden shades are a goldfish bald egg
head shaped bimbo oh because the head i
guess i kind of do look like a piranha a
little bit
um i think that's iconic i think isn't
that funny though
actually you know what the other day
mother told me i wasn't fat i'm just
like obsessed with skinny people i think
and i think that's how you are too are
you like obsessed with people being
skinny like every time i see someone i'm
like oh no oh they're so skinny no
i think you are because you collab with
a lot of like good looking guys and i
feel like there's a collab
with good looking guys duet on tick tock
oh i'm making fun of them
well i think because you secretly like
no because they're [ __ ] boys because
i
think you
did you ever want to be like a good
looking jack i'll tell i'll be honest
when i did water polo in high school hot
i was like i got super jacked and i'm
not and i look good i had a tan
and everything yeah and i'm not gonna
lie there i've got a lot of female
attention at that point
and i quit doing water bowl because it
wasn't worth waking up at five a.m i was
like [ __ ] this i'd rather be fat then
wake up at five a.m
do you still feel that way i mean i
don't no i don't want to be chiseled i
just don't want to be
like this i don't have tits right
i don't think you do i thought you
shirtless over there he was changing
shirtless
i was covering my body but thank you
tick tock showing it you don't seem
self-conscious about your body no i'm
not i'm not either it's not funny how
like chubby people just don't care
what's like whatever
i mean i think that's all shabby people
but i think i think we just have can i
ask you some questions
what is this an interview i thought this
was our thing no i just will well
events i switched to biden everybody i
don't no longer support trump i had a
video like years ago supporting trump
before he even got the election oh
really we're back to biden i saw your
whole hamilton
biting i was like thank god
patricia and doris biden
he's a shoeing for sure now do you think
anyone cares that you enjoy a spider
well if i was like a plant like i
actually swore a trumpet i'm like oh let
me plant and be like i go right and i
was like [ __ ] no not this [ __ ] like and
then they only
vote someone else because they're like
not biting anyone but him because trisha
sports did you see the rock
endorsement of biden no oh you can you
pull up a picture just like
i'll show you on my phone he was wearing
you can show this you can edit this in
right then
he was wearing these uh the tightest
shirt i've ever seen he's got some juicy
milkers bro oh he has titties too
if you have boobs if the rock has boobs
the raw i like chess i would grab
moses's tits all the time he's like what
am i a girl i like grabbing them i think
they're just so fun like grabbing guys
here look at look at his shirt oh oh he
looks good it's like the tightest shirt
i've ever seen in my life yeah
there's something a little awful that's
good to me i feel like that would be
tight on me
you should do a picture like that
because that would be your backyard is
he in your backyard
like literally could do like a parody of
not a parody but just do a recreation
this is like not even a human physique
he looks like a
she's wearing a bodysuit do this and
shave your head
oh that could be fun i wore the glasses
i could be i'd rather be vin diesel is
that okay
because we we joke about vin diesel a
lot i don't even know who that is uh
yeah you do vin diesel fat festival
sounds familiar but i couldn't like
place a face to that
this is so boring but i'll show you
everyone's like who cares
the diesel um what what's he from i know
i've seen the fast and furious every
[ __ ] fast forward
okay let me ask you questions okay wait
do you know your halloween costume
are you planning yours you're just going
to show up in like a party oh we we
agreed i'll do
i'll do the the collab with you the
collab oh the last one but we're
starting next week the halloween
costumes
is that what it already is so what are
you doing next week i can't tell you now
we'll talk off the show i'll match you
i'm not no we're not matching anymore
that was too much pressure
okay who do you currently hate on
youtube the most
oh my god wait what oh um easy who do i
hate
oh you're gonna get me in trouble hannah
it's hannah
yeah i don't understand this drama with
you and han gabby hannah she's like
irrelevant i don't even talk about her
because she gets like no views like
what's even the point we're like the two
like losers that have been on youtube
for so long just going at it and not
getting views for dropping why do you
like hate each other so much
the only reason i hate well i don't the
only reason i disliked her for the
beginning was
she like wanted to be my friend i
finally had to tell her hey you told my
boyfriend i had herpes when i didn't she
told jason i had herpes like before i
agree
with her and then he didn't want to like
[ __ ] me for a long time and then he's
like oh but gaby said i like what and
then she said she told david and all
these people like okay she's weird so i
just cut my distance
do you have her you don't have herpes i
don't have herpes and i would like first
of all she wouldn't know i never was her
friend
then she tried to play it on like shane
telling her that i had herpes which
that's not true but she tried to blame
him because she's crazy
and then she started snowballing on
drama alert she goes i don't want drama
on drama we're giving an interview about
drama that happened nine months ago
and then she goes then she says trisha
tried to call he's like to trisha try to
contact you yeah a couple weeks ago
this [ __ ] is crazy i've never tried to
contact her like she's actually crazy
and i feel bad for her honestly i don't
wanna even like hate on her because i
think she does need some help because i
went through a mental breakdown last
year and i needed to get help and i
think she does too and that's it
but anyways i'll say i didn't like her
who do you hate you have to answer these
questions too
who do you just like oh yeah obviously
keemstar is like
the worst yeah he's the worst he might
be worse than gabby because he's like
even more pathetic like
keemstar is actually the thing about
keemstar is that he's actually just
awful yeah like i feel like like okay so
like even if like let's say
gabby hannah you guys have beef and
stuff and i feel like it's snowballed
but like in a war in a normal world
setting i feel like i could be friends
with her she probably has some redeeming
quality
there's no one that stayed friends with
her she was friends with
a bad example she's like but i feel like
she's she's a human being she must have
some good
like oh like ethan like try to like
flirt with me like she told people that
someone i know like a mutual friend of
ours that does youtube check your
husband wanted me before you i was like
why are you on crack girl like what are
you talking about
but um keemstar is the worst privately
like he'll text me can you just like
stop cause i have all these anxiety
yeah can you tell me about uh yeah he
would like
private text me about the gabby hannah
situation and i was just like
and i was always cool with him up until
this point like even during your guys's
beef i thought it was funny because he
would tell me like merch like keith and
i liked him he was cool like i was like
whatever with him
and then like all of a sudden this like
gabby hannah thing he asked me for an
interview the week before gabby came on
i was like no
like i have no drunk like why would i
come on drama alert there's nothing to
talk about but then second of all so
then he got gabby whatever and then he
was trying to get us to be like
i don't know he was trying to ask me
like oh what's your deal and i was just
like can you just like drop it i don't i
don't want to be associated with her
because she's like actually kind of like
she's off i'm off too i get help for i
don't think she does but
i think it's different when you like off
your meds or something and so then
so i told him i was like i just i really
don't i really don't want to be
associated with it because one
it's not drama that's gonna get me views
at all anyways not that i matter about
that but two i literally was having so
much anxiety that weekend like
there was just a lot happening and
because i do have i do have this guy
that's reoccurring like stock around my
house anyways it's not a big deal but
whatever
and so like people like jump my fence
and i get triggered so i was already
triggered that weekend
and then that was happening he's like
can you just like keep me out of drama
and he's like no i will not and i'm like
okay well i'm gonna block you and then
he posted our conversations on twitter
so then i unblock him i'm like hey can
you like delete those like can you just
like please leave me alone he's like i
will not like he just kept going and
hammering why won't you tell me i'm not
gonna believe you until you show me
police reports like it was just crazy
and i was like who are you like why do i
have to prove it and he was just the
worst like privately he just
wouldn't let it go and i had to block
him again yeah he that's his thing he
god i feel like i'm talking like so slow
now i'm sorry because we
you always put it off at an hour and i
have so much to say and no i feel
that's that's his problem is that he's
like when you talk to him you have this
expectation that you're talking to like
a normal human being
right but he he really is
he has there's something off because he
he doesn't talk to you like a normal
human being
he's always digging and digging and
digging because he wants to produce
content and it's just there's something
sick about that though because like even
like i always said like even off camera
when we
i truly didn't like you like i feel like
you're still nice to me off camera like
you weren't like an [ __ ] to me
because
yeah i was thinking about that how you
know our relationship started from that
one video yeah
but that's the thing is because i you
know my intention was
i felt bad that you felt bad and i
wanted to um
you know i want i wanted to to not be
rude to you of course if we talked off
but even like elo was super nice like
the first dance that was me i was mean
about her i wasn't
saying that she was like didn't stick up
for herself and she was like submissive
yeah
you know what i mean yeah by the way
when i say [ __ ] i mean it lovingly like
i hate that [ __ ] very much i say [ __ ]
like everyone
but the thing like keemstar made ila cry
once like when he uh
after he came on the podcast then i was
like whatever i know you got
because everyone was mad at me and i
left this comment like i know you guys
hate him
i do too but i think we should talk
about him because he's interesting guy
and then he lost his [ __ ] and ela and i
was talking i was trying to calm him
down i was like in the dms with him
being like
dude you know it's not that big of a
deal i didn't mean it like i hate you
it's just a figure of speech
and he was like [ __ ] losing his mind
and then eli tried to talk to him and he
was
he he made her cry he was so [ __ ]
rude and relentless
honestly it was years ago i don't
remember just like words just like nasty
words
yeah i remember like this year he was
like calling like a horse or there was
something
oh yeah he and i was like to me that's
like so gross and you did do that i did
fight back i was like in his defense
because
like you also made fun of girls looks
but at the same like it's just like to
me that's
gross like make fun of people's looks
even if it's for comedy
whatever i think it's just like a low
blow like it's like that's what you're
gonna make fun of someone's like wife
being ugly or something or whatever they
think you know
well i guess i i have made fun of
women's looks but i think it's like that
targeted thing of being like you're a
horse
and then because then they like keep
hammering it and like
this like leafy has it on a on a hoodie
now you made like a hoodie with a horse
yeah it's gross it's i think it's nasty
but i think it's the same thing you did
when you called tana twinkie and then i
came on the podcast and you still were
like yeah she looked like a twinkie
like it's still mean no matter what
because clearly it doesn't look like a
horse and hand doesn't look like a
twinkie and they know that they're
pretty
so they don't care but at the same time
it's still nasty it's just like you look
gross you just like and i i don't care
if people have done it be like oh people
do that for comedy or whatever it's like
that's like a joke that we need people
evolve and like the world evolves i
think that needs to evolve to stop like
bashing girls with looks that's your
thing
like it's a low blow to be like trisha's
fat that's all i hear is your fat okay
if i lose weight then what are you gonna
come for me for you know what i mean
it's like who cares like
that's all you can say about me oh
that's that [ __ ] okay i feel like the
twinkie comment was
was i don't know why i thought that was
is that not different than the horse
comment i'm trying to rationalize it
how your palm is tan bro we said this in
the car i look like a little girl you
literally palmed your tent
your you tanned your palm what happened
there
a little spray tan instead i've been
spray tanning so much lately because i
have the music video so i've been
spraying what
but how what happened to your palm were
you just rubbing it all over your body
or something spray it on me actually oh
my god it really stuck
but there look the hell you're in like
black bomb
it's black bomb
no no can i call a girl twinkie i guess
that was rude of me
of course some people think horses are
beautiful but it's a way you're saying
some people [ __ ] horses and some people
i [ __ ] twinkies but that doesn't mean
you can call it girl that you told me i
look like a corpse in the video about me
yeah well you were laying in like a you
were in a coffin that one i feel like
was fair game
it looked like you were in a coffin i
think that's funny i did say
on a beach whale i think i said it
looked like she
i think it was about you that you it
looks like you just washed up on the
beach
yes exactly so don't rationalize that as
you thought i was a beautiful mermaid
yeah you're right yeah yeah no you're
right it was but
but but like maybe does it get an
exception for being exemption for being
funny
funny i think he's being funny right hmm
who did i pick on that battle when
keemstar and you guys were going out i
think i picked keemstar i think
oh yeah that was the winner i was like
what i was like you are such a [ __ ]
uh
yeah i actually hated you huh you're
such like a judas how you flip-flop
between camps i'm sure you'll be friends
with keemstar in a month from now
absolutely being like yeah ethan's
[ __ ] our head used to go to his house
and you'll make start making up [ __ ]
like
and he put a camera in his bathroom and
he's just called me ugly when i was
house
and i'd be like yeah keemstar you're you
go even told me there's a camera in his
bathroom and i'm like i wouldn't put it
past you
i feel like you loki are kind of pervy
she she trisha goes can i use the
bathroom i said yeah there's a camera in
there don't worry about it
fine with me kidding you can post on
only fans
you do most of the leg work for this
podcast so i could do the most leg work
for our only fans collab
dude i'm just lost by you the emails
back and forth to get the sponsor i was
like i was reading i'm like oh my god
okay look at him just answering these
emails so professionally
you guys were talking about like i don't
even know it was like oh but this for
this and i don't know
i don't even know the words i was so
confused what's happening and then you
negotiated something amazing i was like
oh wow
thank you seriously i was super
impressed thank you i'm glad i didn't
know it was you i was like is this him
answering the emails it's me
it's all me a one-man show i'm not a
one-man show i've gotta i couldn't ever
do this alone dan's in the group chat
shout out to dan's girlfriend so okay
oh yeah it was really cool mm-hmm i do
appreciate the the clips you guys sent
me but you can
people really like the show isn't it
nice like the comments have been really
nice
what yeah it's been all good why do you
have to
spin everything i feel like it's like i
love that ethan just rose trisha for an
hour
by the way that's not that was like one
comment out of many most of them were
like i love their chemistry this is so
fun to watch
no i dig it i like this show it's fun
okay like it's my one outing i like get
dressed up for you i'm like here we go
and then we got a date on monday nights
we always go out somewhere so what about
um oh
this is an interesting factoid so when
you
had beef with uh yeah those are pretty
you can show those
diamonds studded crocs bro i wore silver
ones last oh
and these are after market right yeah
how much how much does it cost to get
your crocs studded i think 100
is blinged up hello that's it yeah
that's badass 200 i don't know
but um i usually order like 10 of them
at a time so she just did ugg boots for
me for winter
so do you just like crocs a lot or do
you think that's like just cool fashion
yeah i think since i got fatter i can't
wear a heel so i've been wearing like
you know you're [ __ ] you know when
your feet start to get fat you're really
[ __ ]
more than knees like put it like
balancing on heels when you're like 200
pounds is a lot
i know i need to lose weight and then i
started eating again i don't know
i think you're i think you made a good
point though i think you you said
you you know what first of all they can
call it a horse i just think
but i think you made a good point i
think you made a good point i can't make
fun of
how women i can't say for example that
you look like you washed up on the beach
so yeah you got to take it and someone
says he looks like i do take it though i
don't i don't think
she's not super she's not offended by it
she just thinks it's pathetic
i agree that's what i'm saying it's like
okay it's pewdiepie like trisha looks
like truck i mean
i'm attractive so i don't care it
doesn't matter but i'm just saying like
it's just gross this is like low i'm
like that's all you got you sound just
stupid
well i agree i think when someone says
that it it makes them look worse than i
think
you know what there's so many things to
come for me for like what would we talk
about fat is like an
obvious like that's what you're gonna
come for me for like there's just so
many other things that's wrong with me
so you've gotten a you've gotten a brief
beef with
anthony padilla is that you say his name
too
and um anyway we talked about it and
we did a highlight and it was our most
disliked highlight of
all time what is people's episode he'll
it'll come around there where people
start
disliking him too it's always happened
well i feel like anthony's thing is he's
like
mega woke you know he defended you when
i made the instagram start
he's like how dare you make fun of
women's appearance so he's like he's
mega woke because he said trisha doesn't
have a mental illness
can i say i've gone i had gone to three
therapists since then
that have diagnosed me with traits of
multiple personality disorder which is
did people like it's two different
things it's the [ __ ] wait no you
don't
multiple personalities isn't that when
you have like a different person in you
it's like super rare if you're like i'm
not trisha anymore i'm
samantha that happens i can describe it
like when i
there is a switch in me which anyone
close to my family or a boyfriend
have all seen it my last boyfriend my
hair boyfriend like it's literally not
me where i wake up the next morning i'm
like i literally don't remember like i
literally don't like it's like this
weird
it is like a switch people get offended
and i swear by it people and but
regardless i have other mental oh that's
for sure
i mean i but anthony was trying to tell
me he rolled his eyes
okay just trying to get on the mental
health bandwagon i'm like aren't you the
one who he always says anthony people
always be like
oh i'm like depressed i'm like you don't
look depressed because that's what you
told me you don't look like you have a
mental health illness oh
anthony padilla you don't look like
you're [ __ ] depressed you look happy
with your girlfriend don't [ __ ] talk
about mental illness or that you're
gonna be an advocate for mental health
people
do you know i hate people like that that
try to tell me i don't have something no
you definitely have something trust me i
had no
i have but the thing flip flop back and
forth oh
trish is pretending to have a mental
health illness for views you think she's
saying
you think she's sane i mean good luck
arguing that same breath to be like
tricia's just making mental films
like what is it but what wasn't his
point and not crazy i think his point
was if i can
mediate anybody because you made a video
saying
i am or was it i have multiple
personality disorder was that the video
and he's like well you don't because
he's like well
there's people who suffer from this you
don't necessarily have that diagnosed
so he felt like um
you were monetizing someone else's
illness
i'll tell you what exactly happened i
watched this video i was a fan i watched
this video on it and i was like
i made that video because i'm like oh
this is probably what i have because i
i've gone to therapist i've gone to
psych
psychiatrists i've been to mental health
hospitals i've been to like i've been
institutionalized not once not twice
three times
that's something people don't know i
went to mental hospital on voluntarily
three times
oh tell me about them um the first time
i know the third time was because
they thought you were suicidal from the
panic first i went twice after
oh what the hell that was a busy year it
was right after you made the video again
not to like put it on you but it was
like right after like that video was
made like it was
it was my birthday my eighth so i
remember that the first time was
february of 2019 that was my birthday
and then i went again in august but what
happened tell me detail each experience
i'm interested
um yeah i mean just
you're shy about it i don't really like
talking about it because i don't like
being judged for that because you know
what no matter what i say people are
like
she's a liar i don't believe her and
it's like i don't i believe you no i
know but i just
i don't even talk about it because it's
just like it's just so traumatizing like
each time you go
like the the very first time i went was
in front of like david and jason and
stuff and it was like so traumatizing so
for them to just act like i don't even
exist after like that really like
no one once checked up on me like after
that like it was literally like so
traumatizing they literally
like take you back from the hospital
like strap you down like put out a van
in your thing because it was it was
[ __ ] awful
so and this in the same time my birthday
too i was
you know i that's why jason finally
blocked me because i drove over to his
house like high on meth
they put me in the thing and um and i
get it i get it he has kids and stuff so
it's like i understand why he broke up
with me whatever but
people are so [ __ ] annoying and it's
like to hear that [ __ ] it's like so
annoying but anyways
your problem is that you have these
really traumatic experiences
and then when you try to talk about it
people don't believe you so to say all
that when i would go to the mental
hospital obviously let me out in 72
hours because i would be fine the next
day
you know they put they i ran out of a
hospital naked because i was not
me i don't even know but they shot the
attitude whatever
i would never do the stuff that i did
and so i um so they never figured it out
so
back to the anthony padilla thing for on
a real note i saw those videos
and this was the time i was like really
struggling like february it was over
march it was when i went on your guys's
show
it was like the morning of and i was
like oh this makes sense like this is
probably it because i really don't know
like when someone when this other person
comes i'm like this makes sense
i wasn't diagnosed with it because i've
gone to people and no one's told me that
they always tell me bpt
they told me bipolar or schizophrenia
they've never once said the thing but
i'm like that makes sense so i watched
that video
and i was like this makes sense and the
first video i did was completely sincere
i literally was like this might be
something
that i have it wasn't until i then that
got triggered when anthony's like
and his [ __ ] dumb ass girlfriend
mikey you also dumb [ __ ] saying i don't
have [ __ ] mental health illness
literally was watching it and rolled her
eyes they were like oh my god this is
dumb
but that was such a sincere video and
that's when i [ __ ] go on the troll
and i was like fine i'll [ __ ] switch
on camera you want me to
oh i'm [ __ ] where am i oh my god like
you know what i mean like
if that's what they want to see to prove
because that's what was happening on
anthony's thing is people just switching
altars
and maybe that happens with people i
don't know i'm not going to be like yes
or no whatever that's not for me to
decide but it's like
i switch but i don't just a lot of
sudden become like you know a different
like oh i'm like
i'm a new person now like you know what
i mean it's not that's not how it works
with me but there is something
and people have seen it anyone close to
me has [ __ ] seen it
jason moses anybody my mom my sister
they've seen it where i'm not
i'm not who i am it's not it's scary i
think
i think one thing i can definitely say
is that you're impulsive and so when you
i i totally understand where you're like
oh i saw this multiple personality
video and you and you're like oh my god
that sounds like what i have
yeah and then you go make a video about
it with you know what i mean like you're
you're impulsive like that but
they they they do the same thing can i
just say real quick sorry to cut you off
but real quick the transgender videos
the same thing
that weekend i just got back from tour
and there was a boy who was transgender
i'm sorry a girl who was transgender
male to female and he looked
like how a male would look but he's like
i'm female i just can't afford a denim
skirt like
he was telling me stuff and i was kind
of like you know i related to that and
that's why i was making the videos like
maybe there's more people who feel this
way
but they're not trying like you know not
doing the transition of course it was a
mistake i realized not like the severity
of saying that but the
the d.i.d thing like that wasn't a
mistake i was just saying how i felt and
how i related to that video
i wasn't like oh i you know i mean i
guess i don't know i don't know what the
title was maybe it says like i have my i
don't know what the title was and maybe
that was a mistake i don't [ __ ] know
but like to
but to to have the audacity to be like
this person doesn't have a mental and to
attack someone for that
let's say let's say i didn't have it but
i thought something's wrong with you so
you're gonna attack someone with a
mental illness i think his problem
i think his point of i think the problem
that you have
is that you you are impulsive
and so you go and make videos without
thinking about it
and then people start to disbelieve you
and they think you're like this drama
machine
yeah and that you make these videos
intentionally and so like i get
why he would think that you know what i
mean because it's like because like
every week
you know it's like i have i'm
transgender i'm just i have personality
disorder
and so people start to think like
what is really going on i get it i'm not
mad about it but anthony padilla of all
people mr [ __ ] woke
if there's something wrong with someone
which there clearly is let's say i am
let's say i have a
pathological liar and there's some
[ __ ] disorder where i'm just like
always needing attention like i have
something wrong with me you don't
[ __ ] attack someone because
something's wrong how about get that
person [ __ ] help
how about butt out because there's
probably other people helping people
don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] when it comes to this stuff
like people don't know [ __ ]
i do get help and guess what sometimes
doctors don't know i've been to three
mental hospitals
three different ones they don't know if
you want to talk about something happy
is it a sponsor is that where we're
going to or no no i was just
maybe changing pace okay yeah what are
you enjoying in life lately
oh um
i don't know did you lose weight for the
did you did you lose weight for the
beetlejuice thing
yeah but also no because like
it's so hard when you like are like i
feel like when you're like in love like
we just went home and he had a tombstone
i'm like okay i have like a slice of
tombstone you know what i mean
you guys can do better than that no we
love a frozen pizza and i i was doing
good i didn't eat dinner for like six
months
let me read you some comments are these
happy are we switching
i'm not really that happy i feel like
i'm going through a depressive episode
right now why i don't know
sometimes i'm just depressed for no
reason like literally no reason most
will come home
to be like sad and for no reason i have
no idea it's the worst i mean that's
worse i don't know oh wow these are
brutal
oh these are some of the comments from
tick tock on your jew oh my gosh
i was only happy well i just had this
prepared
this one i'm not gonna this one is
really i think over the top but i'll
read it
they say every time i leave my house i
have to hide my necklace so i don't
become the victim of a hate crime
how dare you put one on just for fun
well the star i feel like the star david
is a bit much
why well because you're supposed to wear
it's like why why would i wear a cross
i believe in the old testament but it's
not like like the star david is not a
fashion statement it's a
it's a it's a symbol of faith i believe
in the old testament i know all the
stories
but if you believe okay whatever let's
move on i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
argue
biblical studies with you i'm trying i'm
ready
someone says i'm trying so hard not to
cyber that person needs to get the stick
out of their [ __ ] ass it's a star
of david and you guys like you're really
going to be this is also what i hate
about christians and jewish and everyone
i'm christian i'm jewish i'm all of it
how about that [ __ ] judging okay like
how about like stop
judging people jesus you're gonna call
yourself like oh like
especially jewish people y'all don't
believe in hell where am i going why are
you judging me like you know what i mean
like jesus like just walk into heaven
relax
here's a good idea for your next fetish
someone said please don't become a hijab
hijabi next i want thing that thing to
stay sacred
okay first of all yes i don't do that i
wore a scarf in the convertible the
other day and someone's like she has a
hijab on it
this comment has 52 000 likes girl what
are you on
which one which tic-tac was it it
doesn't say no
i'm usually on nothing trish han i think
you just need to pick one culture and
stick with it
i say [ __ ] off because i can appreciate
any culture i want to
she another one says we who is we
because you are not jewish who said that
on what one you don't know where these
are from
what what does it matter i mean you made
a billion jew videos
my boyfriend's jewish i can convert so
you're you're
okay convert and then you could say we
he's not you seen the seinfeld about the
jew jokes
he's jewish of course he's just if you
go he's not jewish
okay maybe he doesn't practice yeah but
if you go to a rabbi he'll say yeah of
course he's jewish all right let's go to
a rabbi babes like you can get converted
but it's not easy you can't just convert
you got to study yeah you would never
you would never go through it i don't
have to convert to be honest but he
doesn't care
the assist did not just say we're no
longer in 2020 girl
we haven't been in 2020 for over 3000
years we're going into
5781 okay okay
jewish humor like what the name is
george washington's tampons that was the
user
george washington tampons not sure i get
that i don't get it either but
we support hamilton we just that's all
i've got
nothing yeah i thought it would have no
they weren't i feel like people come
around to me you know they kind of think
i have like i feel like at first i'm a
little shocking but they know my
intentions are good i truly do love like
the jewish culture
i like learning about the old testament
it's fun
i think you're a good person i just
think you're cr i think you're cr i
think you're genuinely and i mean this
with peace and love crazy
and and i think your life is is a is an
internal battle between
between trying to stay on the rails as
much as possible
while being just totally off the rails
by nature right
but you also played up because you
fetishize or not fetishize but
you your role models are people like
marilyn monroe
and and uh what's that other girl's name
anna nicole smith
and so these are people who are
notoriously a mess
i think they're like yeah so so so you
like being a mess
i don't like it it's just like what i
have and i'm rolling with it you know
like i can't really like this is me
it's kind of like like you said at some
point you just accept like it's kind of
like going back to like
the crazy i accept the fat eggs it's
like oh i'm just kind of fat at this
point why am i trying to diet you know
what i mean like i'm kind of just this
person now
that's fine i'm body positive model
sounds like just look good so you still
like moses
love moses good good good good good good
good good good good good good
that's good i'm glad to hear that yeah
he's the he's literally the best most
patient person in the whole world
he's very patient that's right so
patient like never gets married and i
think that's exactly what you need
i was roasting him on saturday he's like
what does it mean to moses
i kept coming for him and you know what
he did i was being so mean all morning
because the [ __ ] kova testing and all
your text messages dude you're so
annoying the conversations were so
unhostile i literally just said
okay do you mind i said do you do you
mind getting a covid test before monday
and you said sure no problem and i was
like whoa she was and i was like well i
was a
i wasn't sure how she would take that
but she was super cool and then when i
get here you're like
the [ __ ] code this test ruined my
whole [ __ ] day
and i was like holy [ __ ] but at the same
time it was like the cat comment
and like all these other things by the
way we had her get a covid test because
she was off doing some crazy beetlejuice
concert with like a hundred people
first of all 30. every single person got
tested we have to get a cover nurse on
sex why are you obsessed with
beetlejuice anyway it's just so odd i
love beetlejuice i do love beetlejuice
um
i don't know why i don't know i just
like the aesthetic of it i like the
music i like everything
i like the characters i love michael
cannon can we get michael keith okay on
the podcast can i manifest michael
keaton eugene levy adam sandler and
sasha barron cohen that's what
none of those will ever happen your
manifesto taylor comes on the podcast
why would he hey guys i'm adam sandler
i'm gonna sit on this stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] to your podcast
what first of all this is a nice podcast
i'm manifesting that this this is not an
adam sandler tear podcast
i feel like it's totally like bill
murray does those weird ass podcasts all
the time like there's like random people
i got brett michaels on my podcast this
is not a bill murray level
podcast oh no bill murray he's been my
neighbor for real okay
we were in a lawsuit him and my dad were
in a lawsuit together really yeah
suing together yeah oh that's the only
one yeah it was crazy
why neighbors um actually i think the
neighbor was suing them
because they're like their property he
was trying to get their property
something because they were doing like
they were hosting parties or something
it was something like weird like it was
i'd love to be in a lawsuit with bill
murray yeah that's everything he's doing
in my church um
he sued your church no he used to go to
my church tonight
by himself he's catholic he's a super
big catholic oh wow
um so maybe we'll get him on the podcast
or steve martin i made king tut viral
again steve martin if you want to come
on the podcast
please come back come on i love steve
martin those are my people like i love
like bill murray's
i said next martin short on a plane one
time first class and i was with my
boyfriend at the time and i ditched my
boyfriend because i was like wait i want
to sit next to martin short because he's
gonna ask him to switch seats i'm like
no no no i want to say i feel like i
could i feel like at a certain point i
could just
stand in the corner and you wouldn't
even notice i just have so much to say i
feel like we cut it off so quickly and
like i just feel like we have a lot to
say anyways i forgot to say my story
about my sweet moses because on saturday
i was being a [ __ ] like i was just
being a [ __ ] for no reason i don't even
know why i was like i hate driving well
then i just said he driving together
with peter's cats because that was
annoying that day but because we had to
go to north we had to go to northridge
we'd go to where he lived it was like
and then we'd go to the beach we're
going all over the place
and so but guess what he did he bought
me a diamond necklace i was looking at a
necklace
i don't have it on today because i
didn't really you bought her a diamond
necklace moses
i was gonna buy it myself and then i
went to go like i don't know where to go
how much was it
how much you drop on that it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
hand of god oh he got you the hamsa yeah
isn't that nice
but i wanted one anyways and i was gonna
buy it for myself i would never ask
i wouldn't i don't like people paying
for stuff it makes me feel uncomfortable
but one he's not i never paid when we on
a date he pays every single time we go
out on a date
two he got me this diamond necklace and
i was gonna pay for it myself because i
like it
and then all of a sudden he like gives
you you know what the hamsa means he
probably explains yes
yes of course haters haters talk to the
hand basically
well yes the protection we got we like
did the whole like research on it
and it's beautiful i will wear it but i
have costumes so um it's it's gorgeous
it's my favorite thing it's like sony
what are you gonna tell me i can't wear
that someone did tell me that i don't
know you can wear a palm shirt no
someone's like stop wearing those jewels
i think i think um muslims also wear
hamsas right
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not i'll face
it star at david
you shouldn't wear a star david if my my
future husband's jewish
you should moses is saying no star david
oh you should wear david recording no
wonder dude
no it's like saying i'm going around
wearing a cross because i think it's
fashionable i don't think it's
fashionable
it's a universal scene thank you babe i
don't think it's fashionable i do wear
in honor of my boyfriend he doesn't
really like love the judaism but i love
it trust me
i'm not the only one that thinks it's
odd okay well i think if you want if you
want to
walk around with a jewish flare moses go
ahead
i personally don't think it's the same
thing anyways thank you for the diamond
necklace i'm sorry i was a [ __ ] he was
being so nice the whole time he was
being so sweet though
well i still support you guys of course
but once i see moses in the shower we're
going to have problems
for showering with me i'm just saying
his f
i'm i'm just warning you he's going to
do it more
i'm just warning you guys that if moses
crosses the line of the only fans he
will turn you will [ __ ]
ruin you will [ __ ] his life up so bad
and then when
when you guys break up inevitably sorry
you're gonna have a hard [ __ ] time
bro picking up the pieces can we say
we're never gonna break up because there
are so many times we should
this is my way this is my dude you've
been dating not that long to be like we
should have broken up so many times do
you see
the warning signs i'm just saying moses
just be careful just be smart i know
she's
she's persistent let's not see your dick
well we have something planned for
thursdays let's not see your dick on
camera we already have something planned
for thursday that's going on my only fan
so
song
you're in it but not naked oh
okay okay you'll see it i'll show it to
you next week i'll have the picture
are you going to like jerk off on his
picture or something squirt it with me
he's gonna be in it with me the pictures
we have like a photographer coming in
stuff he's in it
oh you're just doing a photo shoot no
it's the whole thing anyways
what is it we'll see if it happens maybe
won't even happen let's see what happens
you're doing a photo shoot how about you
doing a
you think your family will also disown
you well i think a lot of people would
be
really [ __ ] confused there are people
who my wife chief
chief among them be there trust me i
don't want to shower with you
but it's like if they're there it's like
not as weird i really don't want a
shower
i really really don't want to shower
with you
i would rather i would rather i would
rather drag my dick through a field of
glass
also can i ask why you always wear teddy
fresh on our podcast
i wear it in literally everywhere and
everything that's all that works bring
this podcast
no that's my what do i gotta wear i
gotta bring out i'm gonna wear my logo
only trish.com next time i'm gonna just
advertise mine you know i wear
cheddar fresh in every [ __ ]
everything i do but if you go on tv
you're not gonna be able to wear teddy
fresh so that's
like because why because i don't have
clearance for my own [ __ ] company no
the
tv show i don't have clearance from my
own company they do it for clearance
no sometimes they don't because i used
to have my life wow i've never seen a
brand on tv
i've never seen a brand i'm telling you
when i've done reality shows like a
celebrity big brother they wouldn't let
me wear my own [ __ ] like i had it was my
own [ __ ] like logo and stuff and they
wouldn't let me wear it
probably because they're incredible
because they're it's tacky and they
didn't
and it looked like garbage oh and a
giant teddy fresh on your chest isn't
tacky i think it looks fantastic i mean
that's not the best shirt you've had
like you have cute stuff that's not it
well it's different it's like it's a
different thing it's like a
there's like entry where there's like
the mega branding
so that's what this is but the
application's nice it's like puffy paint
i feel yeah
[Music]
yeah it is i believe also james charles
is [ __ ] annoying on tick tock i'm not
gonna lie
like aside from your beef my sister sent
me this one have you seen of him singing
oh i love that video i can't but it's
like weirdly mesmerizing oh the one
where he did
i like your gucci shoes you like my
skechers not that one
no it's the one where you're like what
do you know that one yeah yeah
i'm obsessed with that video it's just
so bizarre you got him on the podcast
like loki i feel like he come on he
would never he hates my guts
i feel like james charles loki likes me
well he doesn't like me i'll tell you
that
he unfollowed me after the beef oh we
used to follow you would follow me
yeah because i don't want to see your
[ __ ] vagina ever
if you want to see my vagina it's on
twitter actually peters it's like
it's too much i can't believe i want to
know what family member of yours hates
me now who said that
nobody no they were mad at me because i
was like no it's not like my dad doesn't
care about oh my god oh i know oh
wow
because they're like i s we spent all
this time
and you just try i was like i was i mean
i was like okay i'm sorry i feel bad i
don't know why you're
we always that's so funny but my you
know what i i really wanted to say
is just like well just don't watch the
podcast
because i'm gonna talk about everything
my parents don't watch myself because of
that like yeah like i
i've i've trashed my parents and they've
they've never said anything and i know
they watch
and like and i just i resp first of all
i love my parents and i respect so much
that they give me the space
to do my thing and they never try to
intervene and be like
you know what you said really hurt my
feelings right and so i think it's
really
cool that they let me you know come here
and speak
my mind and be and be true to myself
when i'm on here
yeah so i will exactly i have to
so yeah i would just you know say don't
watch
but i didn't say that but now i did
don't watch
i'm never going to do another dinner
again which is totally fine actually
you're uninvited good my family honestly
has made me appreciate my family so much
more this family
issues with both of you around like wow
my family is cool as [ __ ] i just think
they were like tightly wound but i'm
like no they're cool well you probably
you
you've like put them through the ringer
early on that is true yeah
they know they're just happy that you're
like
well you're pretty successful i mean
[ __ ] it's pretty it's pretty great
and now i have moses to like parade
around because my dad loves israel like
he's very christian and so he goes over
there and looks at all the jesus stuff
like he's been over there
multiple times so like now i have like
my good israeli
boyfriend who's like knows a lot about
the bible who's also kind of like a
jesus lover you know like all of that so
it's kind of nice
how do you feel about it do you ever
feel fetishized by her moses
no thank you babe i don't i love him for
him it's not like i'm like ooh babe put
on a yamaha like let me get wet right
now like that's not
it put on a talmud and [ __ ] me
she would do that it was a tall mood oh
it's like the the thing you wear around
your shoulder oh yeah we got one for my
dog yesterday we put them in yamaha that
sounds respectful
i posted zero judaism in my life without
her
well she exactly right okay you're
welcome i'm bringing it back
i just kicked your dog i'm so [ __ ]
sorry holy [ __ ] he doesn't care he
didn't move at all oh he looks like toto
he's so cute he's such a good dog's
pretty cute my dog is a little cuter but
this show's over like indefinitely
or just today now we have beef because
you've insulted my dog next hello
all right well we're coming we're coming
to an end here next week
so have a costume we're not coordinating
anymore
is it what's today is it almost october
already it's october 1st on thursday so
october 5th
wow that's crazy i have a costume i will
come in costume so don't be like shocked
i'm coming in costume no it's going to
be fun i'm
genuinely excited okay i'm not going to
go i'll just warn you right now i'm not
gonna go
in as hard as you do i start slow i'm
gonna build up you are
yeah okay cause i'm probably just gonna
buy some [ __ ] on amazon
[Music]
and be like hey i'm mario or something
you know what i mean like a story behind
what you want to be but yeah
because like ela's a designer why
wouldn't she like she should make you
something like
well it takes time to design to make
clothing you know that
of course i get all my clothes custom
made takes like a year
oh like a whole like line right yeah
okay
but i'm excited i can't wait halloween
and wait
what else anything else you want to
touch on before we wrap it up um
[Music]
no i guess i like skechers i like gucci
shoes i wish i could play that for
everyone you can't is it like copyright
by him
well it's a song maybe i could just play
that sound bite have you ever just
real quick because you never really we
never really went into it because i
really do just want to know have you
ever
like thought you were gay you asked me
that last time why do you keep asking
i did what was your name do you ask
everybody that i forgot that i said no i
think that the gay dreams you never were
like
oh so you think you're having dreams
about me [ __ ] dudes
and it's somehow my fault it's not your
fault but i just i wouldn't know i asked
everybody honestly no
experience no never kissed a guy
i've never had a gay experience i mean
like crush
did you ever crush on a guy no wow
i've not had a gay experience who's your
dream girl besides ela
my dream girl like growing up did you
have somebody that you were just like oh
you know like jerk off to him i mean i
mostly
yeah i was mostly like girls at my
school that i liked not like
models or stuff really yeah i didn't
really have celebrity crushes
wait really so who was the girl at your
school what'd she look like
the girl that i was in love with when i
was like in elementary school
and she had like red hair
which was weird because i'm not
generally tracked but she was really big
no no not at all really redheads usually
have giant boobs
no she was she wasn't she she she was uh
slender you like skinny see i think
you're upset skinny people too i am too
everybody i'm not obsessed with skinny
people just
ela's very thin she's very thin your
crush mind you every guy
no i think i i think i'm like i love a
skinny guy
i think cuz we're chubby so we like to
look at a skinny body because we're not
that
i mean i guess i haven't analyzed it too
deeply but like yeah i guess i
yeah i probably i probably do have a
preference for people who aren't obese
okay anything else
i mean not ob so i'm i'm joking um you
know what i will say i'd go either way i
either want someone to be really skinny
like everyone is like really skinny or
i'd rather just be with a really obese
person i think just go crazy
yeah let's [ __ ] kill ourselves with
wendy's okay well i don't want it
the health part aside i don't mind uh
because like after this show i always go
get fast food and like the last time i
went to burger king
there was this really obese guy and like
i'm not even being funny at all like i
literally was like i bet he like [ __ ]
really good like that was my first
thought it's like
because the way he was move walking in
he was like
he was like he was like slithering in
and i was like how do fat guys [ __ ] good
i don't know i've never been with
someone like i've never been with
someone i think that's my own
i think their mobility is very limited i
don't know
i'm fat and i like [ __ ] i can like i can
be on and write all the time you know
like i like i'm pretty agile i'm pretty
athletic all of a sudden like in the
better i'm like oh i'm like i'm like
getting a workout
yeah but you probably just move your
weight around
no you know what i mean you put my
weight around well because like you can
just move your weight around and [ __ ]
not necessarily like lift yourself up oh
no i lose myself oh i totally left
myself for sure that's like the
whole point of having big boobs so you
like bounce up and down but one day
moses
say our bellies rub together he's like
oh it hurt because your belly rubbed
against my leg oh
my belly rubbed against you during sex
he said it was painful
yes he said it was painful oh my god
there's too much pressure on your poor
body
crazy he's like oh my god your belly
having my
belly he was like i'm i'm being smashed
he does have to be suffocated but it's
mostly by my boobs it's not like one
time i sat on my face but it was when we
were like
when we were like high or something but
that was the only yet but what i thought
was good
you suffocate him with your yes always
just like
nasty he said he's not from someone with
biggest boobs his mind moses is saying
no
don't go here you like me moses is doing
this
off camera okay nevermind
well anyways see moses comes here and
chaperones because
because this affects his life so much
because of his family watching
but it doesn't doesn't care like maybe
oh he cares you should have seen his ass
doing this no not about the family i'll
say a final note on that situation with
the families in general just families in
general
maybe reevaluate why the person in your
family isn't telling you everything
maybe
maybe you're judgmental maybe there's
something in you i think it's a two
week two roads i think you're being
defensive of your boyfriend which is
sweet
i'm just saying but i do think that
moses has
some kind of problem communicating
things but why and obviously i know he
has his reasons but i'm just saying
right
i'm just saying it's a two-way street
you're a family judgmental his family's
judgmental
okay fine but like you still have to
live and and you still have to
i feel like it's a two-way street
and you've got to meet in the middle and
they're not mad at you they're mad at
moses
perfect just kidding love you guys can't
wait to see you at the wedding
i just hope when you guys break up you
haven't ruined his life we're not
breaking up at all ever
because i feel like that's what you're
working towards no if anything i've
helped him if we break up like girls
will probably hit him up
but does this his life it doesn't matter
he's not revolting he's more girl crazy
than you think
okay fine but like i don't think he
he's very sex-driven if that's what
you're saying okay in general like more
than you think he says he's not but he
is
well whatever who cares why you shame
why are you kink shaming your boyfriend
i'm not i'm sex driven too
i told him that i was like i feel like
when we don't have sex like my mom my
period we do have sex on my period but
it's mostly in the water but i'm just
saying like
when we don't have something close what
water what water
every water shower jacuzzi bathtub you
have period blood in your jacuzzi
no when i'm a period you get in the
jacuzzi because it doesn't go your
period doesn't flow when you're inside
of water i don't know why that is what
that can't be true it's true in the
shower you don't bleed down or anything
how do you know how do you not know this
you've been married i feel like that's
not a science
i feel like that you're bleeding in your
jacuzzi can i tell you why moses knows
and i'll tell you why
because he said it's because like back
in the day like when you'd be like
swimming in the ocean or the lake or
something like that your your vagina
like dries up to block anything from
coming in
so kind of like it like dries up so
nothing comes out so it like blocks like
little pesticides from coming into your
vagina
you how do you know what is that true
it's a theory okay got it we have to
distinguish distinguish between theory
and fact here on this show
okay we take the truth very seriously on
this show
do we yeah and then and then how many
times a day do you guys have sex i'm
curious oh my god we were talking about
this the other day like we used to have
sex like all the time but now it's just
like morning and night
what do you mean oh i mean two times a
day is probably more than i would be
wanting to have
um it depends though too like oh like
when we fight like the next day we'll
have sex like four times throughout the
day like for some reason we get super
horny
i mean the problem is like who has time
to have sex four times in a day
well when you that's like [ __ ] like
you gotta do something else with your
time well you're just like laying around
and then that but when you fight you we
didn't have sex with like two days like
okay so four days four times
that's always so much fun because then
you're just on the couch like let's have
sex during quarantine it was like a lot
like six or seven but now it's like
six that's like all you're doing is
there anything else to do six or seven
especially like okay after the necklace
too i was just like so horny i was like
oh my god i need to like blow you right
now
it's like it's just you get like so
sexual when someone buys things no one
ever bought anything so then i was like
oh my god so then we definitely
yeah or dinner we always [ __ ] after
dinner like if we go out on a date and
then
it's like chick-fil-a or like a night no
nice deal or like in the middle of the
night i we love i
one i'll just say it real quick and then
we'll wrap it up but one time
and i can we get full permission like
like during sleeping time like i love
being woken up which is like a dick in
me
so one time like my ass was like out of
the bed and all of a sudden he started
having sex with so fun
but i i like that and i tell you okay
yeah you give him you give him
permission so there's no violence
he feels bad after him like are you sure
i'm like no don't say are you sure
because i like that i like
sometimes in the middle night we just
have sex like randomly like so it
depends sometimes when we're sleeping
sometimes when we're awake it just like
kind of depends are you upset
are you excited about the presidential
debate tomorrow and after a shower we
always have sex because we're clean huh
oh my god we're way over presidential
debate tomorrow um yeah
i'm down i'm ready for it great i was on
larry king one time talking about the
presidential election larry king what
the [ __ ] would he ask you look it up it
was on the oracle channel or something
like that
[ __ ] tricia paid his ex larry king
yeah when mitt romney was running i was
on after the debates and he was like
interviewing me and the young turks had
me on
yeah i can talk for commentary dude
you're straight up like jaw rule from
the
chappelle show let's see what trisha
paytas has to say about this
no it's online style like look up all
right i need i i need your political
commentary for next week after the
debate
so watch it tomorrow okay i mean i will
first tonight yeah okay
all right we're gonna wrap it up we're
way over thank you guys for watching
uh as always thank you for support and
thank you to our sponsor of course
because you know if i don't think if we
make money i think trisha is not gonna
have any motivation to do this
no i'd like to be around you like i like
the jew energy in here oh god
just wrapped up thanks guys we'll see
you next week